so let's think a little bit about
retirement and I know some of y'all who
are younger like hey I'm just trying to
figure out what to do with my own life
why am I already thinking about my life
when I am in my 60s or 70s or or even
later the first thing I'll tell you you
will life will go by faster than you
suspect I'm not at retirement yet but
I'm about halfway and that that first
half went awfully fast and but the more
importantly the earlier you start
thinking about it the more likely you're
going to be in a situation that's a good
situation when you get to retirement
so the whole principle is when you're in
your 60s or 70s you might not want to
work you might want to see the world a
little bit you might want to spend more
time with your family or you might not
be in a position to work there your your
health might start going in certain ways
and so you want to have a cushion to
live off of
now one consideration is is that people
are living longer and longer and longer
which is a good thing but in the old
days when the life expectancy was 65 or
70 and people retired at 65 well then on
average they only have to think about
well how am I going to live for that how
am I going to support myself for those
five years but now folks are living into
their 80s 90s and even Beyond as
Healthcare gets better and so now if if
you're fortunate your retirement might
be decades it might be 20 30 years or
longer now that's a double-edged sword
because Healthcare is getting better but
Healthcare is also very very expensive
and so you need to think how do you pay
for that you might have to think about
things like inflation everything is
getting more expensive over time some of
you might say hey there's government
programs there's there's government
Health Care you have things like
Medicare you have social security that
you're paying into but you really don't
know when you retire in 30 40 50 60
years whether those programs are going
to be the same and to what degree are
those programs able to actually help
support you
so we're saving for retirement is a very
very important thing but some of the
core principles that we talk about
saving generally apply so you should try
to live below your means spend less than
you bring in
you have that savings now some of that
savings could be four things that are in
the short term it could be a safety net
in case you lose your job in case you
fall ill in case you have some un
unforeseen expenses it could also be for
buying a house or buying a car and it
could also be for investment and if you
start saving and you invest now one if
that investment's not something that you
you want to touch for 30 40 50 years you
could probably deal with a little bit of
ups and downs what's often called
volatility a little bit of that risk and
so if you invest it over many many years
whether it's in something a little bit
riskier like stocks or something safer
like bonds that interest that compounds
year after year it will become a
significant addition to whatever you
directly save over the coming over the
coming decades I encourage you to watch
videos on Khan Academy about the power
of compounding interest and things like
that but it is a lot if you save a
hundred dollars when you're in your 20s
and it compounds at four or five six
percent per year that will be a lot more
than a hundred dollars when you get into
your 50s 60s and 70s so start thinking
about retirement it's never too early
and you know worst case you think about
retirement you start saving up for it
that money that you're saving up can be
used for many many many different
purposes depending on how you're saving
it you also have things like retirement
accounts like 401ks and IRAs which we'll
talk about later which allow you to save
for retirement in a very tax efficient
way so we'll talk about that in more
depth in other videos